[Music]
this time dr michelle oakley kicks it
into high gear
as she squares off with a big pig no
to curb its appetite for destruction my
husband's wrestling aboard
and a herd of caribou face a 1 600 mile
journey home
but when one passenger suffers a rare
reaction she's kind of dragging her head
and pawing like frantically
the team scrambles to stage a roadside
rescue oh yeah you're looking rough
after a brutal winter haynes alaska is
coming back to life
the coastal town brims with creatures
out to meet their mates
and grab some grub
[Music]
but for the area's canine residents
springtime
is high time for a killer disease
an outbreak of parvovirus is starting to
spread among the local pet population
hey salty
do check out that and i'm gonna see how
quick i can pinch you
in the spring in these parts of alaska
and the yukon parvo outbreaks
happen every year we've got one just
amping up right now what the heck that
was fast hey
next at the american bald eagle
foundation
dr michelle oakley holds a vaccination
clinic to keep the virus from spreading
bring us
come here all the dogs are getting out
and visiting with each other
and so purple just takes off parvo is
passed through a dog's stool
it causes fever dehydration and internal
hemorrhaging
parvo can kill them you know kind of
overnight
so we're like okay we better get this
everybody vaccinate as fast as we can
pinch there oh done girl what's the
dog's name
much no that's what it says the breed is
mud
oh salty okay
no she's no okay today michelle's
daughter sierra and vet tech tracy
are on board to help control the chaos
oh drama
it's starting to get a little crazy in
here
oh oh puppy breath these vaccine clinics
are so important
because i'm not here all the time so
they can get that done and they don't
have to go you know 10 hour drive or a
ferry to get care for their pets
way to go when you do come people are
just so thankful thank you for coming
here we were so concerned
they're all done you probably didn't
notice thank you
they didn't even yeah so um it's
it worked out great today i think my
finger went right into his back door on
that one
just remind me to wash my hands
oh look there's deer right there with
one crisis under control
michelle and her daughter willow head
into a winter wonderland
to tackle another are we almost there
yeah
so we just passed a sign for moose
mountain
in far away saskatchewan cold weather's
still hanging on
we're in moose mountain and we're up
here to catch wild boar
the concern with wild boar is that they
are actually fairly destructive
they're an invasive species they'll eat
young deer
tons of frogs and there's a lot of
concern for some ground nesting birds
they're quite large they're quite nasty
so they need to do something about it
today michelle is meeting dr ryan brooke
of the university of saskatchewan
to help stop the rampaging boars hi hey
how are you
dr brooke leads a research project to
collar and track the nuisance animals
our biggest challenge with wild pigs is
this really high reproductive rate
these animals are having one two almost
three litters per year
they can spread disease to humans pets
wildlife
livestock so the question is well what
do we do
today's field work also entails a family
reunion
oh look at that
willow's dad has joined the pig patrol
you miss me
yeah shane and i both travel for work
um in the summer he's a firefighter in
the winter he does wildlife captures and
so
he's out on the wild boar work he's the
net gunner
doing the actual captures and coloring
i'd like to
put that on you know where you are at
all times
while shane and willow catch up michelle
gets the lay of the land
so this is the park area this forested
so this is actually the
all the movement data from the gps
collars but as you can see there's
really significant movement
one of the most valuable animals in the
study is a 275 pound bore
named m1 we've had a gps caller on ml1
for two years now
yep and mm1 is outside of the of the
moose mountain and getting into farmland
m1 is so important because he is a major
traveler
he's traveling to various groups of
females and he's basically leading the
researchers right to
where the other wild boar are living
knowing where the herds are hiding is
key in helping determine how many
animals there are
and how to control them he's our go-to
guy
but there's concerns about mo1
fertilizing other females
this m1 is an adult male he's probably
sired
hundreds of piglets if not more so we
want to study and try to understand
these wild boar but we don't want him
out siren more offspring
okay well it sounds like we need to get
to work yes let's do that absolutely
to stop m1's reproductive rain michelle
and shane will launch an aerial assault
hello to track down and sterilize the
big breeder
but there's a catch we've got to
approach this operation a little
differently than we normally would we
wouldn't want to just
castrate him because we want him to have
his hormones
we want him to have a drive to find
sows and other wild boar just make sure
that the tusks
are hooked over the top okay so our plan
is to give a vasectomy today
snip snip um the testicles will stay in
place
and we'll just remove the ability to
make more piglets
with her gunner in the back seat
michelle's also got an ace at the helm
pilot mike ree mike can move animals he
can put them
anywhere you want them i'll drop down
but to catch m1 first they've got to
find him
they can get into some difficult terrain
here they can get back in the bush it
can be hard to find them
they're really sneaky
a gps tracking team is already in the
sky homing in on the signal emitted by
m1's caller
and reporting back to michelle and the
crew hey i'm starting to pick up a fake
signal
m1 is holed up somewhere below the
chopper
we got the coordinates and we're flying
into the spot and we still can't see
the wild boar the paint is coming right
down
by that creek it's lots of snow a couple
big open lakes
little patches of trees you'd think we'd
be able to see them
oh here he is right here
it's up to shane to bring him down with
the net gun
basically now we're just trying to move
him out onto the ice into a nice open
area so shane can shoot the net at him
but part of a wild boar's secret to
success is its ability to evade humans
he knows the game so when he stays in
the trees we can't get down low enough
to get a shot so
we've really got to get him out on the
ice to bag the boar
mike must maneuver the chopper within 30
feet of the ground
without crashing into the trees
here we go
the 275 pound boar may be caught
let's go but he's strong scared
and ready to fight
all right to secure the angry pig
michelle needs to hook the snare around
m1 snout
he's bleeding a bit from where he's
biting down on the snare this is normal
he's not hurt at all
but we can't hold him like this for long
we've really got to get him down
a dose of anesthetic should knock him
out within a few minutes i'm just going
to inject it
that's where you put that i can see
shane's a little nervous as i'm coming
at the back end there because
you know his bum is right by the borer's
bum
he's got a right ass
[Laughter]
now it's a waiting game for the drugs to
hit the borah's central nervous system
just hold him to the ground you let him
up too soon he'll drag us across the
field
or worse come back at us this guy is
really big and
so much stronger than he looks for his
size too it's really important to
control their head
because they have four or five inch
tusks they're sticking out of their
mouth they're razor sharp
he's still moving his tail
[Music]
no
wild boar are destroying the countryside
to help curb their population
michelle needs to give this prolific
breeder a vasectomy
but his anesthetic isn't kicking in
[Applause]
giving him caffeine or something
they're super aggressive when they feel
caught they will come
right at you and you know there's been
some near misses already
they need to get the boar down
but his adrenaline's pumping on
overdrive
there's no choice but to give him more
drugs yep
my husband's wrestling aboard i'm doing
some vet work
can't beat it
the extra dose does the trick he's not
fighting anymore at all is he's deep
sleep
with m1 down and out michelle can
finally start his vasectomy
okey-dokey about to start here
their anatomy is just a little bit
different from domestic pigs
skin is so tough it's like dulled my
scalpel
in one cut well bore a hairy beast so
you know there isn't a ton of hair on
the scrotum itself
a little different way to work on them
hey but what's surprising to me is how
thick the hide is on these guys
that leathery skin helps wild boar
survive the harsh northern elements
and each other during territorial combat
when they're fighting they really want
really thick skin
over important parts of their body like
the testicles
with m1's tough testicles finally open
michelle feels inside
now it's kind of a fishing expedition to
find it
i'm getting a little bit of the vas
deferens which takes us
the semen from the testicle out
michelle removes a half centimeter of
the vas deferens then ties it off
okay one down and one to go
this animal will still have all his
hormones um he's gonna go back out in
the wild he's gonna find lots of other
groups of pigs and he's gonna save this
team hundreds of hours
in terms of looking for wild boar he's
still all boy
and these are durable sutures so he
won't have to come back and see me next
week to get him out
one final injection will reverse the
anesthesia and wake the sleeping
giant usually it takes you know four to
ten minutes for them to get up after the
reversal
um but sometimes it can be a little bit
faster
okay
with darkness falling there's no time to
wait for the board to come too
usually we wait until the animals head
up at least but we're out of daylight
and
for safety's sake we've got to get out
of here but the gps team is still in the
sky
keeping tabs on m1 when they hear the
telltale signal from his caller
they'll know he's back up and at them
[Music]
somewhere in the bush below m1 is on the
move again
he's okay he's got himself back up to
body temperature
and there will be no more babies
[Music]
michelle will be back to saskatchewan to
knock other super breeders
out of commission willow and shane are
going to take a little daddy-daughter
time
and we will all meet up back at home
but for this traveling vet home will
have to wait
she's on her way to help a friend who's
hauling some unusual cargo
mike miller and his wife kelly called
because they're moving some caribou
from british columbia to the alaska
wildlife conservation center where
they're from
they've asked me to come along and i
think it's actually a really good idea
to have a veterinarian along
hey guys michelle hey how's it going
good to see you yeah nice to see you
yeah
standing between the caribou and their
new home are nearly 1500 miles of open
road
yeah the older ones are in the front
okay the bigger then all the calves are
in the back
okay these cables are being donated by
the british columbia government they did
dietary studies taking them out and
letting them loose and see what they eat
yeah these guys look good they had some
extra ones that they wanted us to
adopt and that's what started this whole
process how's it going so far
we're half a day into it we've got like
a day left and oh yeah we're just
getting nervous
it's a big deal to take caribou anywhere
but for that long of a trip
if there are any issues that happen at
all you know it's very difficult to deal
with them
it's a long trip you know it is a long
trip longer than they've ever gone
the drive's pretty intimidating when you
think about it you know all the way
across the country with
wild animals boy if we ever need any
have any trouble we wouldn't know where
to begin and
that's why we need michelle you got
enough snacks i'm only going if there's
good snacks
okay everybody's looking good the
trailer is equipped with four cameras so
the team can keep an eye on their
precious cargo
okay you get some sleep i'm gonna try
all right
but in case of emergency they'll have
limited options
international regulations require that
the animals remain
inside the trailer until they get to the
alaskan border
there's a special seal that the canadian
food inspection agency puts on
all the doors of the trailer and they
just want to ensure that
you don't let the animals accidentally
get loose to the time you get to the
border
so there's no getting into the trailer
if something goes wrong
even if one was bleeding i don't think
you could break that seal
if the seal shows signs of tampering at
the border crossing
the caribou will be sent back
getting a little busier in there i hope
they're enjoying the trip as much as we
are
they need to just relax yeah it'll be
over before they know it
[Music]
before the trip began the caribou were
given a tranquilizer to help them endure
the ride
this particular tranquilizer it really
just takes the stress and anxiety away
from you know their psyche so they can
just kind of relax
and chill out and get through the trip
i'm wired if you need me to drive i'm
ready i'm here to put my time now when
it's daylight
so you might think a long trip like this
would be boring but
we're kind of mixing up who's driving
and
um there's no shortage of things to see
caribou
oh yeah hey they're looking at us as if
they know we have their
cousins in the car having some snacks
lots of snacks
it's just such an amazing trip
we're not too far into the trip and i'm
watching the monitor and
as i'm looking at it i see something
that that is not right
this one's looking a little funny mike
oh yeah
yeah she's backing up so she just keeps
backing up
and digging backing up and digging
may be signs that the long-term
tranquilizer isn't sitting right
there can be side effects with these
tranquilizers they protect most of the
animals
but they're all individuals and there
are some then that will react in a
strange way
and see how she's just constantly
digging
and her head's down and she's kind of
like oh my gosh
she's frantically pawing and then she's
dragging her face and not just a little
bit of a scrape i mean she's like
dragging her face as hard as she can on
the ground and if she continues to do
that
she could cause abrasions and injuries
to her teeth or her her
her skin it looks like she's yeah like
she's progressing then you know
yeah no we need to find somewhere to
pull over
without immediate intervention the
caribou's repetitive behavior could
cause her heart rate and body
temperature to spike
and lead to sudden death i definitely
need to intervene
but because we have a steel trailer for
crossing the border i can't get in there
and get my hands on this animal like i
would normally
yeah that's not good it's got to stop
she's going to hurt herself i need to do
something
that's awful
11 caribou are on a 37-hour journey
to an animal sanctuary in southern
alaska each was given a tranquilizer to
help it endure the trip
but one of them is having a dangerous
reaction to the drug
yeah that's not good she's pawing in
kind of a manic way
and now she's starting to drag her nose
she's
really tensing up and that will actually
start to cause her to overheat
left untreated the caribou's heart and
respiratory rates could climb
out of control leading to sudden death
to stop her spiral the caribou must
receive an injection of midazolam
a valium-like sedative okay
but there's no easy way to administer
the drug
canada seals the trailer and they're not
not allowed to break the seal
the team is prohibited from opening the
trailer doors
just have to try and get it through the
hole here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah you're looking rough with only a
couple of inches to maneuver
michelle must inject the needle squarely
into the caribou's flank
so i'm doing the best i can with this
tiny little slot in the side of the
trailer
but it's really tricky to try and
maneuver the stick pole in there
and you know actually inject in the
right spot in the animal not injure any
of the other caribou that are milling
around the area
[Applause]
[Music]
you want another syringe no it's all
still in there but i want another needle
the first needle just bent a bit because
she started to run
every second the caribou goes without
the injection her self-inflicted blows
get worse like she's dragging her face
really hard
all right the full dose is finally in
she should start to slow down she's
still going you can see her
but it doesn't seem to be working
boy he doesn't look that much better so
far why don't we drive for a bit to try
and cool her down
[Music]
i'm hoping in the next few minutes we
see a change in her behavior
if this doesn't work i'm gonna have to
get in there and get my hands on her
okay it's been 14 minutes if i have to
break the seal and go in there
that's it shipment's over they can't go
into the united states
the pawn has stopped
oh she looks way better okay
i thought this was gonna be a boring
drive where it's left the whole way
the drug should have a calming effect
for four to six hours
but for michelle there's no relaxing on
the job
i don't want to take my eyes off of that
yeah
you know kind of the air of road trip
snacks and fun is
gone until we cross the border
[Music]
by the evening all passengers are
hanging on
but it's touch and go
it's a powder keg in there i mean these
caribou are not used to being confined
they're all kind of starting to look a
little crazy they want to get out
michelle uses a pit stop to try to
soothe the herd
caribou candy since they're not yet in
alaska
international regulations prohibit her
from opening the trailer doors
so she delivers dinner drive in style
but i put a little bit of this in there
chewing it immediately
so something to do they got the munchies
the road trip munchies just like we do
there you go
the willows satiate the caribou through
the night
and all morning long until they reach
their new home staters anymore
i don't know right we're all exhausted
but
um the good news is we're in the home
stretch
after 37 hours and 1600 miles
the caribou finally arrive at the alaska
wildlife conservation center
where they'll roam free in a 15-acre
enclosure
here's the turn-off
i mean they've been in this little tin
can for 30 plus
hours so i want to watch them as they
unload to make sure i don't see any
signs of limping
lacerations or injuries okay you're
almost done
as long as everybody looks good you just
never know what's going to happen
when you release an animal until they
step out of the trailer and start
exploring their new home
everything good here we go
oh come on everybody come on
[Music]
here we go after traveling 37 hours
cross country
11 caribou have made it to their new
home at the alaska wildlife conservation
center come on everybody
come on now it's time for their first
taste of freedom
come on guys
[Applause]
it's like they fell asleep and woke up
in a foreign country or something they
don't know how they got there so they're
a little leery of their new surroundings
[Applause]
nice they look amazing
once we let them loose i really felt
like we really accomplished something
and it just felt good to see them come
out and to run around
and to be free they look super bright
there's nobody limping
they're all excited looking around even
nibbling at grass already
oop here come the mamas here they come
all right guys the female that had
everyone so worried
is back to her old self that was a long
trip hey
their new home yay-hey
hey nice to meet you here champagne
nice driving nice driving i'm really
proud to be a part of this so bring in
these caribou
getting them a new home it's been a
journey in all senses
and i'm glad it's gonna have a happy
ending hot shower
so excited
with the new day michelle doesn't have
the option of sleeping in
she's up with the sun in haines alaska
where duty calls at the american bald
eagle foundation
all right buddy buddy at her clinic only
a wall separates her clients
and some of the deadliest predators on
earth i just had to lock the door into
the eagle pen because everyone likes to
leave the office and walk into the eagle
pen with their little chihuahua
here michelle performs regular checkups
on all the birds of prey
hey how's bentley but today's for the
dogs
he jumped off of our porch it's about a
10-foot drop probably
this is a definite puppy pile our pets
are just like little kids going to the
doctor is not their favorite thing
okay if he whips his head up it could
break your nose
if they pick up even a sniff of the vet
stink they often start
quivering right away are they down
sweets
oh she's scared that wasn't me i swear
see just the top bit of the nail there
is split yeah
sorry sorry the most dramatic nail trim
ever i just do my best to
help them relax and make it a positive
experience oh that looks tender
we're gonna give her some antibiotics to
help her along with this but
sometimes i just have to deal with the
fallout
[Music]
oof poor sasha
come on come on homer listen up
michelle's next patient is a
five-month-old coonhound
with a mind and nose of his own come on
buddy
come on buddy homer get over it hey
he didn't get no breakfast today so he's
like scouring
coonhounds are known for possessing one
of the most sensitive sniffers in the
canine kingdom let's go
come on let's go see the doctor dave
stickler has kept the breed for over 15
years
but almost as soon as he brought homer
home he became concerned that something
was wrong
come on i noticed he had a little bump
on his neck and then all of a sudden
it's
like growing and i'm going like i'm
bringing this guy in to see the dock
come on his friend huckleberry recently
died of old age
and his 17 month old pup also named
homer succumbed to cancer
call me a worrywart but kind of
concerned about my puppy
come on homer hi come on how's it going
homer's got him something going on uh-oh
i had a flea collar on him
yeah and he had a rash so i took that
flea collar huh
oh okay a little while later i noticed
then he had a little bump
okay and now it's still getting quite a
bit bigger you call me a hypochondriac
no dog i don't know it's understandable
understandably dave is really sensitive
he's still not over
homer number one um he got this
wonderful new puppy and
then suddenly he finds a growth a mass
on him that's growing quickly
just hopefully it don't happen to him
he's going to want this dealt with
quickly and we're going to help him
oh you're so wiggly but before michelle
tends to homer's lump well he's got all
his
big boy teeth oh thank you she'll check
out his other puppy parts
coat is awesome so i'm getting homer on
the table and trying to get him settled
um he's just so excited and playful and
wants to give kisses he has these long
soft ears um beautiful brown eyes he's
just a sweetheart
so no other lumps or bumps anywhere near
any during the daily patterns
wait don't go yet he's in my treat
pocket
he's crazy that way he's got two
two in the pocket as they should be all
his squishy parts feel good
homer passes his physical now it's time
to inspect his suspicious mass
then we can get him to lay down come on
that's a good boy
belly rub the growth on homer's neck it
could be a little cyst it could be
a small wart but also could be something
more insidious oh boy
there we go okay almost looks pustily
how about i poke it put on the slide
we'll have a look yeah
so the first thing i want to do is
actually just aspirate this mass i want
to take some cells
and look at under the microscope give
them a distracting little pet there
homer hold still homer so
yeah he can take a break i really just
hope we don't see any sign
of you know a really nasty cancer cell
there are several
nasty types of tumors this could be and
dave does not need that right now
i'm gonna have a peek at this
[Music]
it's definitely not just a little
infected person no it's it's definitely
a tumor
[Music]
want to play what do you want to play
come on play
dave stickler recently lost a young dog
to cancer
now his new puppy has a suspicious lump
on his neck
michelle's not sure what it is but a
look under the microscope
yields clues it's definitely not just a
little infected post at all
after looking at the slide it looks
pretty clear that it's not just a cyst
okay i'll chat with him
okay so
bad news is it's not just a little
abscess it is a tumor
[Music]
good news is it looks more like a type
of tumor that
actually might go away on its own in a
few months
[Music]
it sort of looks like a type of tumor
that's common on young dogs called
histiocytoma
histiocytomas are benign if that's what
he has
then homer's home free but diagnosing
tumors through the microscope
is never certain you know i'm not like
100 sure just looking at a slide
we can leave it and watch it and see if
it starts to go away on its own which
they often do in young dogs but
we wouldn't know or we can remove it
right now and i'm totally fine with just
getting it out of there because i know
your favorite history yes yeah okay
i'm not entirely sure what it is it's
growing quickly the best thing we can do
right now is send it off to the lab
and hear back what it is awesome first
surgery boy
don't worry we'll contact you soon okay
all right
oh homer do you hear dad leaving we want
to get started quickly you know we have
to sedate homer
do a local you're so brave for a baby
a cocktail of drugs will relieve homer's
anxiety and put him to sleep
okay homer you just chillax we'll just
put the lights out
if homer's lump turns out to be cancer
he could face a grueling fight for his
young life
it's hard to cut on him his skin is so
floppy
in under two minutes okay there's our
lovely friend
homer's tumor free this doesn't look
like there's a bunch of roots going
deep just close that up clean tissue is
promising
but only a pathologist can tell if the
mass is cancerous
all righty ready for the lab hi homer
time to get up homer's waking up so
all is looking good he's up and ready
okay so he it went great yeah so
anesthesia was perfect
no problems at all so just removed it
now that i've reassured dave it's you
know and tried to get him not to worry
it's trying to keep my own worry down
kind of keep my worry hidden look who's
here
hi homer hey little buddy
oh yeah he took a little nap lab results
should come back within a week
there is nothing worse than getting news
that you don't like to deliver and then
having to call someone especially after
they've lost one dog
gotta keep our boy healthy with the
young hound's future unclear
the only thing left to do is wait
good news or bad as soon as i find out i
have to let dave know either way
come on homer
good boy
[Music]
michelle gets her mind off homer's
pending test results
with a trip to the country she's headed
to honey hill farm
where a flock of shetland sheep is
expecting a new batch of babies
so i'm here today to visit mike and
penny and their sheep farm
they have 40 or 50 head and about 11
pregnant females that are getting rid of
lamb
hailing from the scottish highlands
shetland sheep are prized for their
hearty constitutions
and luxurious fleece we've got a little
bit of
enterprise involved with processing and
selling wool
we've bonded very nicely with the sheep
now one of their mamas to be is showing
signs that she may be unwell
hello hi so you have some sheep for us
to look at i heard
[Music]
last year a young you named kalina had a
grueling labor while trying to give
birth to twins
they were both in the vaginal canal at
the same time
oh okay well it was that doesn't work
it's a one-at-a-time kind of a
situation there yeah both her lambs died
during delivery
we don't want to stress her too much for
sure it's okay mom
now kalina is expecting again and her
physical condition
doesn't bode well this year she's fat
oh yeah she's big yeah she is big
i'm concerned about her she's looking
huge much bigger than the other ones
okay okay girl okay all right when they
get really fat it sets them up for some
problems with their metabolism
you know she's at risk for the pregnancy
toxemia like when she's this big
yeah pregnancy toxemia is a disorder
caused when the eu doesn't get enough to
eat it's all right it's all right it's
all right
oh my gosh how much does she weigh
overweight ewes
are most at risk because there's little
room for the stomach to expand
and take in nourishment you know it's a
big cascade of things going wrong
the mom's not getting the glucose she
needs and she needs glucose to run her
brain
let's get the glucometer ready it'll
kill the lambs
it'll kill her and it can be fatal like
that um so i think we should take a
quick blood sample we can check her
glucose level
okay and see where she's at okay if
kalina's blood sugar has fallen
too low michelle may have to perform an
emergency c-section to deliver her lands
it's all right it's all right it's all
right but to get the blood sample they
need
kalina must be restrained and her
nervous energy is spreading
okay everybody okay everybody slow it
down i can't look overhead
[Laughter]
are you okay okay kalina's really worked
up
sheep are trampling over everyone oh you
poor big girl oh my lordy
it's getting a little too chaotic here
in this small space so
we need to slow it down just focus on
kalina and try and get the sample
quickly
all right okay easy it's okay
michelle only needs one drop of blood
for the glucose test
oh that's all right any second
the centas will know if the young mother
and her unborn lambs
are going toxic it's okay
[Music]
okay okay okay okay a pregnant you is
shockingly overweight
putting her at risk for a deadly
condition
good job sweetheart i'm so sorry a blood
test will tell if she suffers from
pregnancy toxemia
oh good okay so she's she's okay
awesome so the test indicates that
pregnancy toxemia is not an issue with
kalina
her glucose is normal actually so that
all seems great you want to hold that
leg
sure okay all that's left is a physical
exam
to make sure this year her baby survived
delivery
poor buddy i want to get in there i want
to feel if there's a lamb starting to
come out
just kind of see at what stage in labor
if any she's at
that looks pretty swollen it does around
there
so i'm just making sure that there's not
a lamb that's stuck that there's not
again two faces coming at once that
everything feels normal
hold on my left i know i know i'm not
going in any further it's okay
have you noticed her pushing at all or
anything no okay
you know just because there's feet right
there the cervix is pretty much open or
the feet are there or they're coming
as i'm in there palpating and feeling i
can feel movements
of the fetuses in there so that's that's
good news
they're heading in the right direction
and everybody feels happy and healthy
and she's starting to dilate i think
she's just she's just starting is what's
going on
okay i gave a little stretch as well and
that's just going to stimulate her to
grab the lambs
and really that's what she needs
as long as kalina remains pregnant she
runs the risk of developing toxemia
okay it's all right it's all right she
needs to to get the lambs out or
there's gonna be trouble if if she
doesn't lamb in the next couple days
then
we we should you know induce her and and
get her moving
so keep me updated i'll have my phone
going i'll be ready for the text up
there
they're on their way out well we'll
definitely let you know okay
[Music]
as a new day shines on hanes alaska
michelle is back at the american bald
eagle foundation
where important news has just come in
a few days ago michelle removed a
suspicious tumor from homer
a five-month-old coonhound puppy
now she's about to tell his owner
whether the mass is cancerous or benign
hello my phone says it's dark girl
your phone is right my phone says it's
mr stickler
yeah i do so i just want to talk to you
about it
and so it is a benign tumor
um it's that histiocytoma the one i told
you about that young dogs tend to get
it's it's the best news we were hoping
for
well good i'm i'm glad of that but i've
not had that good
luck here lately yeah it feels great to
have good news to give dave today
i mean it was not that long ago i had to
give him the worst
news so i'm just so relieved and i'm
just
excited to make his day and we're both
smiling this time
just watch that spot make sure it
continues to heal up nicely but there
shouldn't be any other issues or any
other reasons to bring them in
okay why not thank you so much michelle
for getting back to me
hey no problem okay bye-bye
yay love giving good news
[Music]
it's been an exhausting time for
michelle traveling cross-country and
back again
but now she's finally made it back to
home sweet yukon
now she can do something she rarely gets
to do
relax with her family smoothies yeah
go for them what's going on you guys
don't want them
it's crazy weeks like this that make me
really appreciate just being home
yeah i don't think we maybe that needs a
bit more blending
i love kind of doing nothing just
hanging out with shane and the kids oh
my gosh you guys
check this out this is that
uh sheep i was telling you about kalina
that was like huge
and having some issues with your babies
look at
she just had them oh my gosh yay
after a difficult pregnancy kalina had
her lambs
on mother's day we're more worried that
the babies were going to be stuck we
were watching her really closely but she
did it all by herself
yay normal birth weight for a lamb is
between
four and seven pounds but kalina's twins
clocked in at seven and eight pounds
apiece
the santas named them kali and kai so
kalina looks great she gave birth had no
trouble there she has two healthy lambs
and that's really good
as long as lambs are nursing quite well
and she keeps eating good she's gonna be
fine
that one kind of looks like me can we
adopt one
no one's adopting anything it gives me a
good feeling to wrap up such a good week
when everyone's doing well and now my
worry is gone so i can just rest up
until the next call
why don't we go out for breakfast how
about that
[Music]
okay
you